Your answer here can actually be any number of things. As long as the
coordinates that you pick, x and y, can be substituted into this equation and
make it true, they should work. We can play around in the graph to find a few of
those points. Keeping in mind the scale of either of our axes, we can go over 1,
and down 2 from our y intercept of course, to find the point 1,8. We can do that
again, to the right 1, down 2, and that gives us 2,6. We can keep doing the same
thing, over and over again. We probably want to move in the other direction as
well. If we reverse what we are doing in x, so we move to the left instead of
right, then we need to do the opposite in y as well. So we need to move up,
instead of down. So to the left 1, and then up 2. That gives us negative 1,12,
and so on and so forth. Once you draw enough of these points it's time to
connect them with a line.